Hi, it's Eyeboy,
and we're here in the square and Talla doing a bit of canvassing today.
And I have to say the reaction is overwhelming.
So many people are supportive.
So many people, of course,
know me from the radio as well.
the one thing that we have noticed is everybody is looking for change.
People don't wanna vote for the same old parties over and over again.
They want something different.
They want common sense and they want a real voice in Europe.
So please,
if you're anywhere around and you see me countless and hop along,
say hi. Because I will be the real voice of common sense
and the real voice of change.
We can do this together. Noel Boylan,
the only man! No. 1! Give me a vote!